MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm
Mano Marks.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Maps API team.
This screencast takes a look
at Autocomplete, which is a
part of the Google Maps
API Places library.
Autocomplete allows you to
do something simple.
As users type in input, you
suggest results to them.
These results can be addresses,
restaurants, cafes,
landmarks, cities, states,
anything that is included in
our places library or our
geocoding service.
So why would you use
Autocomplete?
Autocomplete has
two main uses.
One is for people who are not
sure what they're actually
looking for.
So as they type in things that
suggest things that sound
like, or look like what they're
looking for, and are
architecturally relevant to
the location that they're
looking at.
And the other is, if you are on
a mobile device, you have
very few keystrokes to get to
the result that you need.
Now if you've ever used a
mobile phone, typed in
something, tried to get a
result, you know that it can
be much more laborious than
using the keyboard.
So Autocomplete helps you
solve that issue.
Now, the Autocomplete API is
part of our JavaScript API,
but we also have a web service
that can be used in a variety
of formats on the server side
or on a mobile device.
So I'll invite you to check that
out, and there will be a
link to the documentation at
the end of this video.
Let's take a look.
So this is a map of
San Francisco.
And as I start typing in, you
can see that it's starting to
give me results that
are contextually
relevant to San Francisco.
I typed in T-E, and I get a
variety of things in San
Francisco and Berkeley--
which is nearby--
that might match that query.
And as I click on one of them,
I'm going to say look at the
Tenderloin.
Tenderloin's a neighborhood
in San Francisco.
I click on the marker, and
there's some additional
information.
With a few lines of code, I've
added this powerful search to
my application.
I'll go ahead and close
that window.
Now, say I were to go
looking for pizza.
Pizza's the traditional demo
of choice for maps.
I'm going to type in Z-A-C, and
you'll see I get Zachary's
Chicago Pizza.
I'm doing this because Zachary's
is a popular pizza
joint in the San Francisco Bay
area, but it's in Oakland.
So I'm going to go over there,
and we'll look at that.
Click there, and I've got some
more information, and even a
link to the Google place page
for Zachary's Chicago Pizza.
Now if I were to take a look
again, and start typing in
T-E, you might notice that the
results are actually different
than they were for when I
was in San Francisco.
Now, the application
hasn't changed.
The only thing that's changed
is that the map has changed
focus to Oakland instead of San
Francisco, and you'll see
I get contextually relevant
results to Oakland.
I can also search directly
for addresses.
So, say I wanted to type in
1-6-0-0 A-M. I get 1600
Amphitheatre Parkway, Mountain
View, California--
it's Google's address.
You can see here that this is
a very powerful tool that
allows your users to interact
directly with our places and
geocoding services without you
having to write more than a
few lines of code.
And then once that result is
returned to your application,
you can display it on the map,
or you can pull up additional
information about it if we have
it in our places library.
The last feature I want to
mention is that you can
restrict the results returned
to either a
establishment or a geocode.
So if you do want to just have
an address search, or just
have something that searches
for businesses on your map,
then you can certainly
do that as well.
So that's Autocomplete.
A few lines of code, you're
up and running in no time.
Take a look at the
documentation.
You can click on this link in
the video, and it'll take you
right there.